ja und jetzt die absage was genau es die
begründung warum durch die menschen
jetzt nicht auf die straße gehen
genau die versammlungsbehörde hatte es
vorhin ganz frisch vermeldet dass eben
mehrere demonstrationen jetzt diese
demonstration hier der antigona gegen
korona gegner
verboten werden sollen und die
hauptbegründung ist eben weil man aus
dieser demonstration am 18
gelernt hat dass sich die teilnehmer
nicht an die geltenden maßnahmen bei
einer demonstration halten also sagen
gilt ja immer noch munter nasenschutz
tragen und 15 meter abstand halten und
dass sie sich bewusst dann nicht dran
gehalten haben halt viel mehr absolut
dagegen sind diese maßnahmen einzuleiten
wir haben das ja auch selber beobachtet
als ihr da man da wurde gerufen maske
weg maske weg man sollte keine maske
tragen wenn wir als reporter dorthin kam
und eine maske an hatten wurde nicht mit
uns gesprochen also die sind da wirklich
konsequent dagegen diese maske zu tragen
und auch den abstand einzuhalten und
genau deswegen hat man jetzt gesagt gut
wir haben es den damals vorher gesagt
ihr müsst euch an die maßnahmen halten
sie haben sich bewusst nicht dran
gehalten und deswegen wird es jetzt
diesmal verboten weil es ist damit zu
rechnen dass sie sich auch diesmal nicht
daran halten und im senator geißler hat
sich auch schon dazu äußert er meint das
ist eine entscheidung gegen die fed
nicht keine entscheidung gegen die
versammlungsfreiheit sondern eine
entscheidung für den infektionsschutz
man muss bei diesem teilnehmerfeld ja
sagen egal aus welchen spektrum sie
kommen reisberger sowohl wie die
menschen die jetzt gegen nicola
maßnahmen sind sie alle haben eigentlich
gemeinsam dass sie nicht in erster linie
auf das hören was die regierung sagt bzw
generell erst mal dagegen sind also mit
was ist jetzt am wochenende trotzdem zu
rechnen dass all diese menschen wirklich
einfach zu hause bleiben
damit ist eigentlich auf jeden fall
nicht zu rechnen weil wie du schon
gesagt dass diese leute viele dieser
leute sehen die regierung als den
hauptgegner eigentlich als in hauptfeind
manche sprechen auch von einer diktatur
in der sie ihr leben einer corona
diktatur dass da alle überall eine große
verschwörung hinter stecken würde womit
die regierung hat die menschen
unterdrücken möchte ihre ziele
durchsetzen wollen also die das wird sie
jetzt nur noch mehr darin bestätigen
dass man wohl versucht ihre meinung hier
zu unterdrücken und deswegen erst recht
da hinzukommen aber innensenator geisel
hat halt auch angekündigt dass man mit
der polizei konsequent dagegen vorgehen
wird wenn dort menschen sich nicht an
das verbot halten und sich trotzdem
versammeln